the super bowl uh winning
defensive back uh in his now wow eighth
season in the national football league
and a uh
proud lsu guy and uh seeing claude
edward delaire
do that for um his own team now that had
to be a nice moment
and we're thrilled to have tyron matthew
back here on the rich eisen show how are
you sir
rich i'm doing well i am thrilled
i mean well first of all i'm glad to
hear that you say you're doing well and
you sound good because you said you were
pissed off after the game last night
about the play that you guys had
defensively but before i get to that
i do want to get to first overall what
it was like to play a national football
league game
in a pandemic tyron what was that like
for you i mean i think first and
foremost you know it's a blessing
you know a lot of people you know a lot
of small
people do do big jobs and they give us
the opportunity to
to go out there and do what we love and
um obviously i thought
you know the nfl and the chiefs they did
a great job
you know safety protocols all throughout
camp uh
and then even leading up into you know
the game last night
um you know it kind of felt normal you
know even though
you know in reality you know things are
a lot different
what were you able to lose yourself in
the game
like did it feel like you were playing
um
any other week one or like say a week
five week 10
outside of everything else
no i mean i think i think for us as
players you know
i think it's easy to lock in you know
especially with us having been able to
have fans at the game
you know not all of them but 22 of them
they were still loud they were still
able to
you know we were still able to kind of
feel their energy um
so for us you know like i said you know
for the most part
it kind of felt normal um but we were
locked in
you know we weren't you know obviously
not playing football
you know for months and you know you
know getting in training camp and having
to go through all that you
you just you just want to play the game
you know uh man i felt like a lot of
people you know a lot of guys on our
team especially they they were just
trying to their best to just focus on
the game so you feel safe
playing this game tyrone is that true or
not yeah yeah i do 100
uh like i said it's a lot of small
people that that do a lot of big jobs
you know uh from the training staff to
medical staff uh to independent people
um who who uh you know have to do
certain things um
i feel i feel like the game is safe
right now yeah
tyra and matthew here in the rich eisen
show and uh let's talk about the show of
unity beforehand
um the the conversation uh sitting on
twitter
where i know you you reside um matthew
underscore era
um that uh the conversation was is that
booing me here is that is there was that
did you hear the crowd when you're
standing there
tyron at the time rich i i didn't
okay um you know obviously i heard some
blowing
um initially you know when the texas ran
out of the locker room
you know but but that's normal you know
when the visiting team comes out of the
locker room
so i didn't really that wasn't
surprising um but as far as when we
uh locked arms and displayed unity um i
didn't i didn't feel like i heard that
okay well that's that's good to hear um
those of us sitting at home we did hear
that and
you know i've been to kansas city many
times that city's got a huge heart and a
huge sense of community so i don't want
to broadly paint an entire brush
by saying kansas city has an issue with
uh those who are standing in
a form of unity in 2020 with what we're
seeing going on
in the communities around this country
certainly when it regards to social
justice and what's going on
um on that front um so what are you
thinking about this morning
tyron well i think you know
us as players um you know and even you
know within our organization
you know us having that respect us
having those conversations um
you know guys being you know free to
to to do um or express uh
you know in every way they have and they
have the support of their teammates
and you know the support of ownership
and you know and
i just wish that that the fans you know
uh supported guys um
and their views you know and uh just
continue to listen
you know continue to listen to him
continue to have an open heart
um you know and kind of see where you
know a lot of players are coming from
so what conversations have you guys had
if you wouldn't mind taking us into your
conversations uh on this front
yeah i think i think for us you know you
know as a team
you know um how can we you know
create positive changes how can we
create real change
you know how can you know we show our
support
um to local black businesses you know
how can we
you know change the narrative and you
know make voting cool again how can we
give
people you know um the voice and support
their voice you know how can we back
these people
um i think that that's really been a lot
of the talks of that that we've had um
i know me personally talking with you
know clark hunt and
mark donovan uh you know leaders of our
organization
um i think these people are really
listening
and they're really um finding ways to
to create positive change um you know
within their communities within the
kansas city community and beyond so
i think it's great um you know the kind
of conversation that that
we've been able to have um and i'm sure
we're going to continue to have
yeah i don't know if you saw the moving
video that your colleagues at the miami
dolphins put together about okay the
conversations are great but now it's
time for action now we actually like to
have to
you know get some action going i don't
did you see that video tyrone i know you
were ready for a game yesterday but that
that kind of made a rounds
on thursday yeah i i i i did not see
that that video originally okay
but it's it's really moving and you know
and i i'm thrilled to hear that you're
saying that you're talking to the
highest levels of
uh of your organization because to me
that's where a lot of this action can
come from that's where
a lot of the influence that the nfl has
is at the top of the flow charts
from all um all the teams
uh when you said make voting cool again
i understand that we need to make sure
that all of the facilities that you're
playing football games in
are are coveted free but perhaps when
november 3rd rolls around uh
football stadiums and atriums can be
used as polling places
that these sorts of things can be done
from nfl
ownership are you is that the stuff
you're talking about with clark hunt
yes absolutely and conversation um
you know has been had to try to make it
you know possible for for arrowhead to
be a voting site
and i think that's a you know tremendous
platform that we that we have
you know as a team as an organization um
you know clark hunt
you know all these men they have
tremendous reach you know be beyond
you know the football field you know
deep in communities
you know deep into uh you know politics
um
and i think it's important for us to
continue to to push towards how can we
continue to use our platform
to to bring about positive change to to
continue
to display unity to continue to
have respect for man's a woman's uh
opinion and view and how can we support
that and not
you know try to tear that down and tear
that apart so
um you know obviously you know it's a
lot
um that that that has to continue to
happen
you know to create change in all of the
world you know we talk about education
talk about voting you know you talk
about lack of resources
opportunities and inner cities um you
know this is a big
issue and um so i like i like what the
nfl is doing i like what our players are
doing
um and our 100 support support us
tyrion matthew here a few more minutes
left with the kansas city chiefs
defensive back who made a big play
russian deshaun watson leading to an
interception
in the uh opener so why were you so
pissed off after the game he said i'm
pissed about the the play of the defense
what are you talking about yeah i feel
like you know our coaches challenge us
you know when we came back in training
camp um
you know we have high goals you know as
a defense um
trying our best to forget about last
season and trying our best to live up to
the standard
you know that that we set for ourselves
um i felt like last night you know um
you know we let we left we left a few
players out there on the field
um and you know we can get better you
know we're still a young defense we're
still
we're still fairly new uh in this system
but i think for us the the the standard
is how can we
you know hold teams you know to ten
points or less
i think that's the goal i think with the
kind of offense we have the kind of
special teams
we have um you know if we could do our
part defensively
and cover every blade of grass for four
quarters um
i think our chance of winning is pretty
high so
you know obviously we're grateful that
we play with the high powered offense
but i think that's defensively
you know um we're trying to set a
different standard you know for
ourselves um
we're trying to actually win ball games
you know for our team
uh and not having to rely on you know
other phases of the game
so there's a nice healthy competition
even within the super bowl
winning locker room i i love it and then
on the offensive end
you know uh in the fantasy world
um this kid was drafted high because
everybody thought well
we saw what he did at lsu and now he's
in andy reid's offense
along with you know the rest of the team
and you know clyde edwards elaire
had a remarkable performance last night
did you see that one coming even
yourself
i mean you know obviously i'm spoiled
you know uh
it's a lot of great lsu players uh you
know and i think watching him
you know up close and personal and
having a chance to go to the national
championship
you know watch him play in it um i
always knew the kid was going to be
special
especially in this offense um you know
he's going to be able to really open
some things up and
you know i think him you know coming
from lsu in the sec
he can be kind of a bell cow you know in
a sense
it was it was it was really cool to see
the young man you know um
run the football that well take care of
the football you know sloppy conditions
it's raining out there you know he's
making these big runs cutting on the
dime
you know bouncing off a big tackler so
uh and the houston texans have a pretty
good run defense
you know i played for those guys a
couple years ago and um so it was kind
of it was cool to see the young man
you know do well uh gets a really good
run defense yeah i know and uh
you know i shouldn't leave out eric the
enemy's name too uh
your your oc uh who knows the running
back position
and you know suffers no fools whatsoever
uh it can that's the neat thing is it it
looks like this rookie can take it he
can take whatever's coming his way
um and can you you can write him to
victories
i know it's just one game but it does
appear that way tyron to me
yeah i mean you know i think especially
with our coaching staff you know
the guys that you know work under andy
reid um
you know all of us you know at every
position
you know we're getting challenged you
know by a great coach
and i think that's just the the culture
andy reid has said and
you know i think all the coaches under
him follow that
you know they challenge each and every
player to not only be their best but be
their best all the time
and um but like you said the rich you
know it was one game
um but it was good to see the young man
you know uh
you know live up to being a first round
running back did he get a game ball who
got the game balls last night
tyron uh well i mean no one got a game
ball last night um but if i did give
anybody a game ball rich
uh you know to be all uh all the medical
people you know
uh all the people that work in the
stadiums you know all the janitors
everybody that's wiping down
you know toilets and and sinks and you
know
faucets you know um you know i would
have gave all those people a game but i
think without them we wouldn't even play
the game
last night you're first great man but
you knew that that is good
i mean and and you mean it you're not
just saying that that is a
i would say when you say somebody that's
a great answer
that that supposes or that infuses that
that you're maybe saying it just to say
it but that that is a great answer i'm
so glad you know you reminded everybody
about exactly what's happening to make
us lose ourselves in a fantasy world
that cloud edward delaire is lighting it
up and you're doing what you need to do
um and then i guess a little bit of the
reality world can give us a
a nice uh laugh if we if we can
uh andy reed's face shield
it does appear you need to give him a
windshield wiper for it
uh tyron did you notice that during the
game
i did notice that uh during the game uh
me and coach bree
interact uh a bunch during the game um
probably have six or seven interactions
and yeah you know i did notice that but
you know who am i to to tell big brand
anything you know no i know
i know but i mean it does appear like
somebody's got to give him a little wipe
down or
something uh how because i don't know
yeah it's like a fog
it's like he's got his own personal fog
bowl you know
you know yeah it was the first game too
so
you know everybody's knocking out you
know kinks you know all over the place
but
uh i'm sure i'm sure in the next game uh
for sure
coach lee to make sure you know he has a
personal uh
window washer weekly adjustments they're
crucial to being a championship team i
agree tyrant
hey uh is there anything going on with
your charity work your foundation you
want to get out there
anything that you want to you know my
platform is yours as always as you know
that
yeah well um nothing right now rich um
i'm actually trying to team up with
target um and we're trying to do
something uh for the people of
um west louisiana you know they've been
they was hit pretty hard
uh by the hurricane and you know uh
obviously
you know with the elections coming up um
just trying to
bring more awareness to voter
registration and trying to get everybody
you know up to speed on you know what it
is they need to do
um it's a uh i wouldn't say a
complicated process but
you know it's a process you know to to
register to vote and uh not everybody
has
you know um you know that that
information so uh i think just
continuing to to bring awareness about
that uh
continuing to to spread positive change
and
spread a lot of love around the world um
so that's just where i'm at right now
that's because again voting is not a
partisan issue it's an american issue
it is an american issue it is a
democratic issue we are
we are a democracy and we are a beacon
for it in this world
and voting is important if there's
anything i can do to help you know how
to contact me
please thank you thank you rich i
appreciate it right back at you tyron
congrats on the week one and let's chat
real soon
thank you appreciate it right back at
you that's tyron matthew
kansas city chief safety love that guy
we'll talk about being about it
so amazing what a career he's having
he's putting together a career that
nobody thought could actually happen
right that's his story hey you watched
all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here